[Musique]
c'est parce que les amis j'ai vécu un
vrai traumatisme et je le dis avec la
voix du mec qui est vraiment traumatisé
la [ __ ] je ne suis pas vraiment
puisque je les dis avec la voix du mec
donc peut pas s'arrêter ce n'est pas que
vous laissez moi vous expliquer pourquoi
de l'histoire du début ces derniers
jours j'ai eu un petit dire je me suis
dit [ __ ] mais un test de qi ça
ressemble à quoi déjà je me souviens
plus je n'avais faire j'avais 6 ans je
me souvenais plus de croiser des faits
et de combien de cui j'avais ça faisait
marrer de refaire ça je tape alors test
de qi sur google et c'est là quelque
chose à faire je te raconte des fois sur
intel généralement le même comportement
qu une personne de 50 ans est fou de
cliquer sur un lien je faire un test et
oui tu expliques ça va se passer comme
ça va y avoir des questions tu aurais
minutes pour répondre à chaque question
il ya un total 50 questions blabla bref
pendant une heure je fais ce [ __ ] de
tests là j'arrive à la fin je me dis
franchement j'ai géré le qi va être bien
et tout [ __ ] je m'aime je meurs et je
voulais me suis c'est comme ça et là je
clique sur voir mes résultats et 6
passes
voilà déjà il ya une nouvelle page qui
se charge et tout est là ils disent
merci de rentrer quatre codes allopass
pour avoir le résultat est là tu ressens
la même chose que quand on kidnappe ton
enfant comme ça on lui retire les bras
et les jambes et on te le rend titan
voir le pass c'est alors que j'ai pris
mon sifflé à 5 comme ça j'ai fait non
j'ai préféré perdre une heure de temps
de ma vie plutôt que de perdre 3 euros
pour des [ __ ] d'escrocs même ça c'est
l'anecdote qui sert à rien mais après je
suis tombé sur un site très bien qui
s'appelle m'ont tiré dessus et point com
pourquoi je vous parle de ça aujourd'hui
parce que boya des tests pour faire son
club la paix à des tests une rade avant
avec le cuit et qui sont très
intéressants et quitte enrichissent
vraiment en termes de mécanique de
cerveau et de culture à gaza c'est
fantastique tests psychotechniques tu as
des tests de logique de cartes de
mathématiques de mémoire de mécanique de
verbales et de dominos ça c'est le test
de qi donc temps à plusieurs un il ya
plusieurs tests de qi disponibles chaque
test se présente sous la forme de 30
questions et tu à chaque fois un temps
limité pour répondre à chaque question
moi j'adore tout ce qui émane calcul
mental logique j'adore ça mais avec le
temps depuis je vais plus à l'école que
j'ai eu mon bac et ben je perds du
niveau en orthographe conjugaison en
grammaire je perds vraiment du niveau et
ça me fait chier du coup on va faire
ensemble un test de vocabulaire plus
précisément un test de synonymes qu'elle
est synonyme de circonstance
ok allure expérience 10 convenance
conjoncture prévoyant je ne sais pas et
bien mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est
ça on va tout simplement rentabiliser ce
dictionnaire j'avais acheté pour la
vidéo à huis clos lit donc les
circonstances mec je sais pas je dirais
que c'est conjoncture alors c'est
horrible cette vidéo parce que toi j'ai
bon à tout et tout le monde s'en bat les
couilles soit jefo à des trucs bateau
comme là et là par contre
vraiment humiliée là je passe pour le
bon conte de youtube quel est le
synonyme de apprécié brassard ça va
savourer réunir comprendre règle est
motivé à aller savourer salue le
synonyme de prudence distraction absence
amusement négligence vigilance mais
c'est bien évidemment la vigilance mais
synonyme de sacrilège mots que je
n'avais pas entendu depuis 2002 hérésie
avenant coup je m'en bats les couilles
petit robert c'est le joker je m'en bats
les couilles avenant dis moi quel arrêt
il a mis dans le petit robert dubois tu
l'as mis à la rave niasse merci à
l'arrêt je t'aime qui plaît par son
bonheur sa bonne grâce à mr john eames
était affable mais de façon je le savais
où j'allais le dire c'était un petit
test voir si à l'arrêt y avait pensé à
tout suivant frasques mec c'est chaud là
une phrase que remarquable c'est une
oeuvre une phrase que c'était une oeuvre
dans frasques ce trop gras est moche
pour une oeuvre là on exactement dans ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure je pue
la merde en grammaire c'est minimes de
subterfuges
il a mis au point un subterfuge pour
s'échapper de la cage géré échappatoire
ok je vais aller de converger mais
surtout j'ai eu de la chance j'ai eu la
chance comme au bac c'est sûr alors là
je me suis choristes et pour délétère ça
veut pas dire salut c'est à dire
toxiques et frasques s'était pas oeuvre
c'était incartade
une incartade c'est un écart de conduite
mais oui il a fait une phrase pourrait
vous voyez parfaitement qui se passe sur
ce site mon clip come test verbale ça
c'est le pire
regardez alors dans les tests verbaux
l'autre catégorie qui était cool c'était
le genre mais qui des fois il ya des
mots tu ne sais pas du tout si c'est
masculin féminin alors qu'ils utilisent
régulièrement dans la vie courante par
exemple on dit un aérogare ou une
aérogare on dit une gare pourquoi on
dirait un aérogare jeu c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais point moi même qu'est ce qui
se passe je vous coupe la parole je m'en
fous on dit un aéroport mais on dit une
gare du coup on dit un ou une aérogare
ce que je viens de faire ça ferait une
très très bonne annonce youtube c'est
quand tu dois divertir en 5 secondes
avant que le mot clic sur ignorer la
danse fils de [ __ ] ballet l'ignoré pas
j'ai trouvé on dit un port de bateaux et
un aéroport donc si on dit une gare on
dit une aérogare même c'est sûr c'est
bon alors un aftout unaf c'est un aphte
danse à un moment faut pas me prendre
pour un moustiquaire ou une moustiquaire
non mais quand même quand même un
échappatoire fiscale ou une échappatoire
fiscale
un gérard depardieu une gérard depardieu
un échappatoire je dirais un tentacule
ou une tentacule alors c'est un
tentacule je crois que le terme
scientifique c'est du masculin sur
tentacules un obélisque ou une obélisque
c'est une obélisque alors combien j'ai
huit sur dix plus tard le mec sacre a
joui tandis plus tard et je suis pas
signal alors malheureusement c'était pas
un déchet moteur fiscale mais c'était
une échappatoire fiscale payante ou mai
en france je ne savais pas il est vrai
c'est un obélisque mecs j'adore ce soir
j'en fais 3 4 comme ça d'affilée ça
m'amuse énormément celui qui est bien
c'est les proverbes avec ces fous alors
ça c'est en gros il nous donne un
proverbe il faut trouver dans une liste
de plusieurs proverbe celui qui a le
sens le plus proche vous allez voir mecs
et les premières mec c'est de la folie
c'est irréaliste et là c'est de la
science fiction donc
rira bien qui rira le dernier cas le
proverbe a le même sens la vengeance est
un plat qui se mange froid ou n'est
jamais puni pour avoir fait mourir de
rire
c'est un ami à vous vous dit ça il faut
vraiment s'en débarrasser faute ne faut
plus sur votre ami bien dire fait rire
bien faire fait taire je voulais faire
ça à la fin de chaque mois qui aime bien
châtie bien
je ne sais pas après on verra bien car
les derniers ça veut dire ah on verra
bien à la fin connard squeeze traducteur
ça donne ça donc je pense que c'est la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid
hâtez-vous lentement ça veut dire
dépêchez-vous mais pas trop et ce que ça
ressemble à qui sait peut se hâte de le
débiter rien ne sert de courir il suffit
de savoir viser pardon j'ai ouvert aux
battles en tête du coup je dirais rien
ne sert de courir il faut partir à pour
tout simplement la technique c'est juste
de prendre le pouvoir de base et de le
donner avec d'autres mots par exemple on
ne paie jamais trop cher une bonne leçon
c'est à dire mieux vaut mettre le prix
pour avoir le tout bien que d'avoir
plein de fois le truc nul va y compris
la meilleure leçon et celle des exemples
aux brestois dire ça à mes enfants ce
qui c'était et s'appellera pathé'o la
meilleure des leçons et celle des
exemples elle et va à l'école et
n'oublie pas les codes de la vie n'a
point de vacances je dirais la pensée ne
paie pas de douane l'habit ne fait pas
lemoine ans on connaît tout cela ne
suffit pas d'avoir la tenue d'une nana
pour être pour être comme le nanar
attention squeeze prof de français
tout le monde a le brevet bonté au le
chien ne rêve que d'or pour un moine de
l'abbaye ne faut pas on voit ici que
c'est clairement un piège pour le mec
qu'on qui se dit hey ya moigne dans les
dom donc les avis des uns bahreïn ont il
ne faut pas juger le sac à l'étiquette
c'est ça c'est juste celui là alors on
ne peut jamais trop chiant de bonnes
notions j'avais fosse était pas la
pensée ne paie pas douanes c'était à
quelque chose malheur est bon et pour
tout le reste on avait beau y est je
m'entraîne à faire tout ça parce que je
suis mauvais j'ai des lacunes en
grammaire en verve etc mais en vrai mon
vrai kif c'est les maths mecque et yatai
elle ment de test précise regarder ça
c'est le paradis il faut voir ça comme
un jeu vidéo les maths calcul mental
allez trouver le chiffrement quand 59.9
égale sound of oasis égales soit 155
153,55 à 495 on n'en parle plus fait
question 12 x 3,5 10 x 3,5 et ya 35 des
foyers de saint ségal 7 35% à 42 euros
d'ivoire 87 x x égale 4 135 x 5 7 13 + 6
très égal à face a fait un plat fait
très sûr très ça fait 1 56 / 14 égal à 4
10 sur 10 j'aime bien c'est est-ce parce
que c'est ça que j'aime bien c'est que
t'as pas besoin de connaissances soit
par pour les matins petit pure logique
assez génial la roue attendant le sens
antihoraire dans quel sens tourner la
route c'est pas pareil
une masse de 10 kg comprime de ressorts
identique en série de dix centimètres
quelle est cette distance si les
ressorts sont mis en parallèle
ok ça change quelque chose s'ils sont
comme ça les ressorts rude comme ça
avaya plus de résistance elles
compriment de ressorts de 10 cm donc ça
la lie à 20 cm du pour cinq années alors
c'est quoi manger 10,5 cm c'était 2.5
masse de 10 kg comprimés de recenser
l'idée centimes à chaque fois je me
demandais quel coup de fil au trocadéro
il est temps d'arrêter je donne le
signal d'alarmé
ça suffit eh ben les amis c'est la fin
de cette vidéo d'une médiation est ce
qu'au final j'ai été humilié à vous de
me le dire
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à les achever la vidéo si c'est le cas
j'avais envie de faire un truc sur mon
pied poing comme c'est mon petit délire
du moment voilà ça fait travailler un
peu la matière grise s'écoule à le toit
bouchend'homme ça me regarde et portez
vous bien ça lui a bien toujours
[Musique]